at a Success Academy charter school in
Harlem every student seems fully engaged
with the work at hand the teachers are
in full command of their classrooms and
even the halls and lunch rooms are
relatively orderly and quiet this is a
branch of the nation's most celebrated
and controversial charter school network
where the kids beat the rest of the city
on the annual standardized English and
math exams by an enormous margin what
you've accomplished success academies
founder and CEO is Eva Moskowitz a
former city council member who sank her
own political career back in 2003 by
speaking out about how unions stifle
schools in 2006 she started a charter
school
a decade later success has grown into a
network of 34 schools serving 11,000
kids and it's often hailed as a shining
example of what the school choice
movement can achieve at its very best
this month Moskowitz received the 2016
Savas Award for public-private
partnerships from The Reason Foundation
the nonprofit that publishes Reason
magazine and reason TV and we sat down
with her at that event for an interview
one of the core ideas of a charter
school is that it's partially insulated
from politics oh well I'm not sure that
has any bearing on reality the unions
are constantly suing us the unions block
heated the entrance to our schools a
number of years ago it's just you know
the mayor threw out three of our schools
I mean it's been just a constant battle
to provide this critical service in the
last nine months success has been rocked
by a barrage of negative stories in the
press a low point occurred in February
when this video which shows first grade
teacher Charlotte dial the rating a
student and tearing up her work
was published on the New York Times's
website it was surreptitiously recorded
by a former assistant teacher critic
said the incident was indicative of a no
excuses culture that can be emotionally
destructive for young children the day
the story appeared Moskowitz held a
press conference I can't stand by as the
New York Times uses selective video
anonymous sources and gotcha tactics to
tear down any teacher let alone one with
the track record of Charlotte dial you
said that the paper had failed to give
Success Academy a fair shake why would
the New York Times not be giving Success
Academy a fair shake well Charlotte dial
did the things on the video it seemed as
if there was a double standard because
in the New York City school system you
have teachers engaging in physical abuse
of students you have teachers engaged in
sexual abuse of students and yet somehow
that was not front-page New York Times
story if someone had videotaped me as a
parent every moment of my 16-hour day
with my children I might not come off so
well we all have bad moments but then
the question is why was this
student-teacher recording her in the
first place because I think she was
angry with misdial and she held on to
the video so if you were really
concerned about the treatment of a child
you wouldn't wait 15 months to bring
forth the video but look the incident
was troubling to certainly misdial
certainly to all of us but it's forced
us to have an honest conversation about
what kinds of practices are ineffective
and I don't think the guardrails are
totally clear to all teachers and now we
have an example this is not what we do
and here's why we don't do it I was
doing what I thought I'd needed to do
to fix the school where Howard knots in
my home child the other major
controversy came last October when again
the New York Times broke the story that
a principal at a Success Academy in Fort
Greene maintained a secret got to go
list naming sixteen kids with behavioral
problems that his staff should encourage
to leave the school Moskowitz had
reprimanded the principal immediately
upon finding out about the list before
the story leaked to the press and she
has long rebutted claims that success
weeds out difficult kids we responded
incredibly quickly incredibly swiftly
incredibly thoughtfully then in January
13 families filed a complaint with the
US Department of Education claiming that
Success Academy encouraged their kids to
leave many of whom suffer from severe
behavioral and emotional difficulties
let's just say the worst allegations are
true
she is counseling out the hardest to
teach she's creating this porns private
school why is that a bad thing
that's Robert panda CEO of the education
think tank the Thomas before them
Institute he argues that these charges
are hypocritical because top shelf
neighborhood public schools routinely
council out difficult kids are we saying
that if you are a poor black and brown
kid it's a problem that you should have
what an affluent kid in the Upper East
Side has a disruptive free studious high
quality school why is that unfair a lot
of the criticisms basically boil down to
you push out kids you're selectively got
a go list it's the same stuff you cream
what's wrong with being selective the
parochial schools in New York are mostly
are gone or there's much smaller than
they used to be why can't success be
selective what's wrong with that well I
think there's a difference between
should there be a level of selectivity
and and of course there is in the public
school system in the district school
system right if you're able to afford an
apartment in the PS absolutely catchment
area I don't know what selectivity means
if it doesn't mean that you have to have
a certain income in order to go to that
school
absolutely but also argue that the
gifted and talented programs obviously
that is selective yes but when you look
at the scores in a very wealthy area you
know PS 321
in Brooklyn you're gonna see high scores
and everybody knows that a big factors
demographics Success Academy it's a
largely minority population from poor
backgrounds why can't they also get a
classroom filled with other kids who
aren't going to disrupt the flow of the
class well you know there's the
philosophical Y which I suppose is your
interest but that's not how charter
schools are set up and we are following
the rules of random lottery so that is
the only basis upon which you can select
you know we're a random lottery working
within the confines of that rule I mean
you know it's nice we are we are working
so maybe other tactics for the
selectivity might actually serve your
student population I mean it's like one
of the pioneers of education is that
every classroom can serve every kid but
actually a really disruptive kid steals
time and attention away from the other
kids in that class I think that that can
lead to pernicious effects where a
school is deciding this kid can this kid
can't we want to serve a very broad
we're not a gifted and talented program
that's not our mission our mission is to
be an old-fashioned public school where
you serve the community like all
charters the students here apply by
entering a random lottery and demand is
strong success received more than six
applications for every opening at its
schools next year but compared to 2015
the number of applications actually fell
slightly for the very first time does
that have anything to do with some of
the negative press I don't really think
so I mean it was 20,000 we have 20,000
parents on our waitlist for 3,400 spots
I'm not terribly but it had also grown
every year prior neighborhoods are
different you know we're opening up a
school in Far Rockaway we're very new to
that community so so wasn't seeing the
Charlotte dial video reading about the
gotta go list that's scared any
it said to a small percentage even to
parents who said no I'm gonna look
elsewhere
that's not my impression from doing a
lot of parent meetings you know when you
have parents on the ground that's not
you know most of most new applicants
find out about success from a fellow
parent and our parents experience of the
schools did not feel like the portrait
in the New York Times and there is a
what do they do the parents you talk to
do they like the idea of a more
disciplined orderly safer environment
than they might get at their district
school well I would say first they find
the school incredibly joyful some of
that joy was on display at a recent
Success Academy pep rally that had
nothing to do with sports this is the
annual slam the exam gathering in which
students get revved up for the upcoming
state standardized tests and honored for
their past achievements the difference
between the regular public school the
big story is parents dropping out my
kids shouldn't take the test at all its
success it's almost like a football
rally what's the idea behind that that
event well the idea is just you know why
should there only be pep rallies for
sporting events we want to celebrate
their growth they've worked hard you
certainly didn't get the sense of kids
who feel ostracized for doing well in
school Moskowitz who has long maintained
that one day shall return to government
and run for mayor of New York City is
evolving and how she defines herself
politically when we sat down with her in
2014
here's how she described her views I'm a
liberal I think that liberals care about
the little guy liberals care about
social justice at The Reason Foundation
Savas Awards earlier this month she sang
a different tune I called myself an FDR
liberal I believed in big government
until I met it up close and personal and
I wasn't naturally a libertarian in fact
I resisted becoming one but the more
time I spent in government the more I
began to doubt whether it really was the
public spirited institution that it
claimed to be having other than your
belief in in school choice though are
you
more libertarian in other ways as well
no not particularly no maybe if I knew
more about those other areas maybe I I
would be but I don't really know that
much about health care it's a relevant
question because you have not been
secret about going back two years that a
career goal of yours was to be mayor of
the city of New York and then you're not
just that not the Chancellor of the
Department of Education but the mayor of
the city of New York you announced in
October that you were not going to run
against mayor de Blasio for next term
well I mean first of all is this still
an aspiration of yours yes I might do it
in the future you don't have you don't
have your policies on other aspects of
city government I I did I said on the
finance committee when I was in City
Council and you know I sat on land use
and transportation and so forth you know
the last few years I've been pretty
exclusively focused on public education
and public policy over the next decade
is success gonna keep can we expect a
hundred schools are you gonna do yes do
you have it in are you you still going
to be leading success a decade from that
I don't know a decade from now but but
for the foreseeable future this is you
know it's it's an enormous project and
it is going to take a tremendous
leadership to get it done and I have an
incredibly talented team of people who I
want to support in order to break the
educational sound barrier will you move
to other cities I don't anticipate
there's there's a lot of really Laozi's
a lot of lousy schools right here in New
York okay well thank you Eva welcome
thank you